It's the  part of you that no one can see
But you know it's there and I do too
That's the part of you that no one can take away
Because that's the part of you that's really you
You see the stuff I like about you isn't the stuff on the outside
What I like about you is the other stuff
The inside stuff
Smiles are a little gift we give each other
That's the most beautiful part of yourself
She left you because you're a pussy.
Please don't use a bad word when you can use a good word
Every pain needs a name. What do you think this one is called?
You're not a real person
You are a man in the box
you're a trusted brand
No one sees a man
Feel something new today something's growing inside me
Our next guest raised your son your daughter, your step-daughter please help me welcome Mr.Jeff Pickles.